hello everyone and welcome to one of the
most
important if not the most important days
in your life
uh because i'm going to show you how to
play against the london system
so you might have started a lot a lot of
openings with black against the white's
d4 ideas you might have studied the
benoni the bank we might have studied
the king's
indian might have studied the slav some
traditional lines of the queen's gambit
declined
and then white just uh you know you go
online you play a blitz game and white
just goes d for bishop to f4
e3 knight f3 and you have no idea what
to do and the white just crushes you
every time
uh or or you know maybe not every time
but most of the times and you you're
wondering
uh what is this system in the how do i
play against it and whenever you hear
someone talk about the london system
they say ah it's uh yeah
nothing serious for white uh even if you
remember uh
uh in the last years the world the blitz
championship magnus cross and defeated
the
former world champion vladimir kramnik
with the london system
and kramnik said add a london system
it's uh you know it's nothing but but
magnus is just magnus
so white doesn't really get some sort of
a big advantage out of the opening but
um he has a very natural way of
developing pieces and this is something
that i
was trying to find a way at least at the
counter right from the start
and i've done i've done so by uh
checking out
the the database regarding all of the
games that were played and i was able to
find
one specific line uh that's incredibly
forcing and it really uh
well it forces white to make some very
very
uh well not not so great decisions for
for him so uh to show you exactly what i
mean
let's just start and see what's
happening so white will open with
d4 if we're talking about the london
system sorry about that
uh and this is how you will approach it
you will go knight to f6
white will of course go bishop to f4 he
wants to get his london setup
and you will immediately strike in the
center with c5
and now white will go e3 if white
uh goes for this d5 idea that's really
not another problem
you're just gonna play d6 and after c4
e5 and you are very happy with your
position
if the bishop moves you can even grab
more space with e4 or if
white captures alpha song uh you're just
going to play bishop captures and you
already developed your light square
bishop got him into the game and you're
going to have a very very pleasant uh
position
because you you really have no more
weaknesses once you've developed your
light square bishop
so we're not going to discuss the d5 all
that much so
knight f6 c5 we're going to play e3 this
is what white
will go for like 95 percent of the times
and this is how we will go about this
queen to b6
already going after that b2 pawn and
just a nice early queen development now
it's usually against chess principles to
bring your queen
early into the game but there are
openings that are tailored
just uh in that direction like for
example for example one of my favorite
defenses with black is the scandinavian
defense where you immediately bring the
queen into
the game and you can get a lot of very
very interesting positions
so this position has been has not been
reached very many times but it has been
reached by some incredibly strong
players like fabiana korwana yani
pomnishi
vasily van chuk and i found the game
baskaran adiman also played one game
with the black pieces
and it's a very very playable uh forcing
line that
uh just forces white to make some
decisions so now
you're already putting more pressure
here and you're attacking the b pawn
most of the times we will not be
capturing the b
pawn before we play a6 because it tends
to be very dangerous as you'll see
so here uh white just gonna continue
developing knight to f3 or knight to c3
probably knight to c3 and here we will
play a6 and this is the basis of our
setup so
uh we're gonna play knight f6 c5 queen
to b6 and a6 and
this is basically where our game begins
uh so
what can you do here uh instead of this
a6 i'm just going to show what happens
if queen captures on b2 because we said
we're not going to do that
knight to b5 is just very annoying
because now you're already threatening
knight
to c7 with check and after you defended
knight to d5 you can even go a3 and here
white will be able to trap the black
queen you will get some compensation for
the queen but not a lot for example a6
rook to b1
queen to a2 and now you're just gonna
play uh well
white can either continue harassing your
queen but uh probably uh white will try
and trap the queen and after eight
captures you're just going to play rook
to a1
and now black has no other options but
to capture the rook because the queen
has no squares
so here we would simply see captures and
after capture so we will get to this
position
uh where white has a a a a queen but
black has a rook and a piece for a queen
so we're not going to be doing that
after this knight the c3 move we are
going to go a6
and this is the setup you want to
remember because you will reach it
most of the time so knight f6 uh c5
queen to b6 and a6 and now our position
is great and here we're going to discuss
three lines that uh are kind of most
likely to occur but
only one is let's say a series attempt
for white
so here white could go a3 white could go
rook to b1 or white could
just continue his development with the
knight to f3 so let's see what happens
if we just go a3
so here uh white is inviting you to go
for queen captures on b2 but we are not
going
to be doing that so to make this um a
whole course sort of a course i'm not
saying this is of course this is just
an idea you can use in your games uh
pretty much all of our lines will start
with
c captures on d4 just to make it easier
for you to
enjoy these setups e captures on d4 and
now
d5 we prepared to bring our bishop into
the game and only then uh we are
interested in closing up the structure
with e6 so here
probably you will get knights the a4
going after the queen
but now comes a move you have to
remember queen to a7
looks weird putting your queen here but
our idea is that we want to keep
attacking this pawn and we want to be
able to further attack it with knight to
c6
which will prevent the white from most
of the usual ideas and now for example
knight f3
we're going to go bishop to g4 sorry
bishop to g4
and after bishop to e2 continuing
development we're going to go knight to
c6 and already we have a lot of pr
we have a lot of pressure on this pawn
here and now for example
white can try the normal c3 we're gonna
go e6 and the game continues or if white
tries the more ambitious try knights the
c5 we can just go e6 and after knight to
b3 now the pawn is nicely defended by
both the knights and the queen
we can just continue development so here
just to show you some optimal squares
for your pieces
castle's castles uh and now c3 so white
is very happy with his setup but he
can't really claim any advantage which
is
usually not all that great if you're
white for example knight to e4
and now whatever white plays you will be
able to trade down completely and
enjoy a very comfortable end game
because white it doesn't really have an
active plan here uh if something like
this then you can even go this
but more often than not you will see
something like knight f2 d2
and here you just trade everything off
bishop captures queen captures now you
can either trade or even go queen b6
uh try to put some more pressure on the
knight because now if the knight
captures you can capture that for
example captures uh and then queen
captures on b3
but if let's say rook b1 tries to defend
the pawn as the b file is now in danger
uh rook f38 and now you will simply get
all your pieces into the game
if knight captures on e4 you're gonna
capture on b3
knight to g3 and now knight the a5 going
after knight to c5 and black will have a
very pleasant game
so this is one of the uh one of the
lines that can actually
end uh very abruptly for example white
can choose to go for some sort of an
attack with knight a5 but this is not
just a force to draw
and uh if white chooses to do so then
there is nothing
much for for you to do but you know okay
he played with the white pieces he
insists on a draw that's fine
because white is going for something
like queen g4 but after g6
you're gonna get uh this very nice queen
to e5
with the idea of just bishop h6 and
delivering checkmate but now after this
it's just going to be a a draw
by perpetual uh repetition i'll draw by
repetition because the white is down
material and there's no way to finish
the attack for example check you're just
going to move
check you're going to move and that's
just it
so uh this is what happens after a move
like a3 is played after our initial
setup so a6
and a3 so not very ambitious for white
but it is possible and you should know
how to
uh how to approach it and where to put
your pieces another try is rook to b1
saying okay i'm not interested in giving
up the
b-pawn and depending on what what level
you're
you're playing at uh people might or
might not
defend this pawn but even if they do
we're just going to continue in the same
fashion we're always going to capture
this pawn
captures characters and now play d5
again with the idea of developing our
bishop
and then playing e6 so here uh the the
difference is if knight's the a4 here
you can just go queen c6 now this is a
bit
different because the knight is under
attack and the bishop f5 will be very
annoying
so here basically knight for just wastes
a tempo because if knight c3 bishop f5
and
black just got a free move in so instead
after d5 we're going to continue
developing as that's what you should
always do knight f3
now bishop f5 black has some very casual
developing moves the bishop d3 you can
even trade here captures capture z6
close down this position and after
castles bishop to e7 and again you have
a very
very normal way of developing your
pieces uh for example rook after e1
you're gonna castle and after now let's
say knight the e5
uh usually knight to e5 is something
that is really annoying for black in
most of the lines
but here the problem is always this um
this pressure on the on the d4 pawn
because here if you go
knight to the e5 you can immediately go
knight to c6 and now there's pressure on
the pawn here and not much for black to
do
but for white to do about it if you go
knights to e2 then queen b5
and black is having an amazing position
if the queens get
traded off then this pawn is hanging a3
you're gonna go knight to e4 and black's
position is is
great for example f3 knight d6 you're
going after the
c4 square uh you cannot play b3 the a3
pawn will be hanging so here we would
probably see a set of traits captures
captures captures captures
or something in along those lines and
black will have a very comfortable end
game
so this is what i wanted to show you
that in this line
[Music]
some of the most popular replies from
white
are not not all that impressive and the
black can actually
get a very comfortable position out of
all of them so a3 rook to b1
moves you don't have to worry about and
then there's knight to f3 which is the
most normal way to continue the game
because white is not interested in
playing for some material equality white
usually when you play the london you
want to play aggressive you wanna even
without castling you wanna maybe play
king f1 start pushing the h
pawn uh but this is also a line that
kinda kind of forces white
to to make some decisions and not be
able to go for that right away
but okay if knight f3 we just continue
e6 now we're gonna
continue our development and now bishop
to e2
again the seemingly aggressive bishop to
d3 does not work here
because you just captured the pawn and
after pawn captures queen captures comes
with an attack on the knight
and it's just a very nice pawn grab if
knight a4
queen to be for check c3 now defending
and blocking this
check uh queen to a5 and it's uh
it's a nice position for black you are
you are behind in development but
white will not be able to take advantage
of that for example if castles you're
gonna go d5
and now if rook to b1 trying to get to
that b6 square
just knight f to d7 you guard it and you
prepare b5
so not much for you to do and the white
doesn't seem
to have a clear way of not a clear way a
way at all of taking advantage of any of
this for example
if knight b2 you're going to go bishop
to a3 just develop you can even trade
trade this bishop for a night and here
you're just going to castle and enjoy
your position being up upon
with without a single worry in the world
for example if c4
white trying to open up some lines you
can simply trade captures captures
captures captures and
now just castles and that's it you're
playing b5 bishop to b7 rook to c8
you have a great position you're up upon
you're really enjoying life
so here white might block b5 with a4 but
it's not a problem knight b6
goes after the bishop and the double
attack on the pawn here
bishop b3 now you just shift the knight
here attack the bishop
bishop to d2 attacks queen queen to d8
and now
after knight to e5 let's say now you're
gonna play b6 and
your position is once again outstanding
you're gonna play bishop to b7 once
again
rook to c8 and so on for example bishop
c2
bishop b7 and if let's say queen f3 rook
the c8 and you have finished your
development
uh without much problem being up a pawn
and you can just
you know play this any way you like and
yes black does
white does have this uh very strong
bishop pair but you don't have to worry
about the knight on f6 is an amazing
defender
and there's also the knight on d5 that
defends the knight on f6 so there is no
way for white to put any extra pressure
you have an amazing bishop here going
through
through this entire diagonal and you can
just play normal developing moves and
you have you have a great position
so this is what some of the things that
that can happen if white tries to be
over aggressive so white has to play the
seemingly more passive bishop to e2
but now again we always capture on the
four captures
queen captures and now we are going to
grab the pawn
uh queen captures here on b2 and this is
a
pretty dangerous line but i'm going to
show you some of the lines that
um allow black to capture this so here
white's main idea is knight to d5 but we
are going to discuss this
a bit later on because first i want to
show you what happens if castles if
castles
it seems like this pawn grab is a bit
too much because
white has all of the pieces developed
you only have a queen here
the queen can easily be chased away
however you have a very forcing
knight to c6 now you attack the white
queen and the white queen has to be very
careful
already if a move like queen to d2 is
played just bishop to b4
and that's it white white is just losing
this game
uh it seems like white might be able to
play knight a4 and try to trade off
queens but just queen a3
again attacking the knight and the queen
and if c3
just bishop goes here and now everything
is hanging the bishop is hanging the c3
pawn is saying if the knight moves
knight is coming to e4 with a double
attack
just a terrible position for white so
things can go wrong for white
very easily here so after knight to c6
we will most likely not see queen to d2
but you never know
uh because white might think queen d3
knight before okay i'm not playing that
i'm just gonna go here and then he runs
into bishop to b4 you know it's possible
but okay we're going to discuss the
series queen to d3 now of course knight
b4
with a double attack here queen to d4
and this is where our
fun starts so here it seems like you can
go for the
knight captures on c2 fork uh and in
fact you can but
uh i'm gonna show you why not to go for
it because after knight captures on c2
queen to d2 uh and there's no way for
you to move the knight a rook is coming
or rather the other rook is coming and
you will lose the piece here
and even if you try the forcing bishop
to be for line now bishop to e5 just
defends it
and if bishop captures bishop captures
in knight e4 again with a double attack
then just
captures captures and after uh
sorry knight captures on the two knight
captures on a1 first
bishop captures on g7 going after that
rook and after rook attacks the bishop
captures here
and this is just a straight out winning
position for white
white has a bishop and a knight for a
rook and you will not
be able to play this so do not go after
that
if you're not uh you know do not go
after that so
uh we are planning to capture the c2
pawn but not not just yet so after this
queen to d4
comes a move you should remember that's
queen to a3 so just move the queen and
now you are threatening this
uh and here we will have the knight to
e5 move and knight to e5
is very very dangerous because it
threatens knight to c4
which could trap your queen but this is
why we play
such lines against the london the early
queen development and
we have to make white go for our queen
but white can never capture our queen
that's that's the idea
and here now you can go for the greedy
knight captures on c2 and i will show
you what happens if you go for it
but maybe there's a better idea here you
would get queen to d2
now attacking the knight and after
knight captures on a1 now
knight to c4 challenging the queen and
also
you have now a lot of pressure on that
v6 square and after the queen moves
now comes knight to d6 chick and now the
bishop has to capture it bishop captures
bishop captures attacks the queen
and now white just has a very very
strong grip on the position
it's not winning for white or anything
black might be even better here
for example 94 you offer a queen trade
and if knight captures queen captures
queen to c3 uh goes after the g7 pawn
so a very forcing line king rook to g1
and now the very sorry uh first queen to
g6 maybe even better than rook to g8
and now we're going to play rook the c1
going after this checkmate queen
captures bishop rook captures and
then rook delivers checkmate because the
bishop is controlling this diagonal
but black can play f6 and this is one of
the
one of the cases where f6 is in fact the
best move and now black has
some good squares and while black is up
in material it doesn't
look to be all that that of a impressive
position
for example queen captures here you're
gonna play king f7 and yes you
are up material you're up the exchange
and you are up uh
two pawns but uh i mean it's so hard to
get any of your pieces into
the game uh of course you can play this
but
it's not for everyone uh maybe you know
maybe a bit more activity is preferred
to to material here so we're gonna get
back to that position where knight the
e5 was played
while we can capture on c2 we have the
very very efficient knight after d5 and
now
you have no more worries in in the
entire world you're going after that c3
knight and white simply must react to
this
for example knight captures here you're
gonna capture
on d5 with the knight and now there are
no more
no more serious threats here you're just
enjoying your position uh maybe
move the bishop the bishop is under
attack you can go bishop g3
i will however show what happens if
bishop to h5 it looks
incredibly unpleasant but still you have
to feel very comfortable in this
position because this is actually good
for black
you don't want to play g6 and open up
this diagonal you're going to run into a
lot of trouble but what you will do here
is go bishop c5
attack white's queen and if queen bishop
captures an f7
you cannot capture with the knight
because the queen hangs so bishop
captures on f7
you're gonna move the king and now
you're gonna ask white okay what is
happening with your attack
is there even an attack happening here
your queen is under attack and once the
queen moves
now just remove the defender of the
bishop and you will say thank you for
the peace
so here we'll probably see something
like bishop captures an e6
uh knight the knight is now under attack
so knight to f6 attacks the queen
queen to f5 uh getting the queen
somewhere
to help out with the attack but now
bishop captures queen captures and
finally
the most important uh capturing of the
piece d captures an e5
bishop captures now with some pressure
on the knight here so just
rook to e8 attacks the queen queen to f5
again with some
nasty uh pressure here but just bishop
to e7
and black is perfectly fine now it seems
like you're
able to do something but uh make no
mistake white is down in the entire
piece here so this is very very
uh difficult to play and the white
doesn't have a clear way of breaking
through here if we're okay to b1 you're
going to play b5 you're not going to
allow this rook into the game
and now it seems like it's kind of
difficult to uh
to defend against this and make use of
your extra piece but there are a few
ways you could go here
and try to try and trade off the queens
like this you could capture here
go here then go here so a lot
a lot of possibilities even maybe moves
like pushing the h pawn and then going
rook to a5
going after the queen so you have to you
have to test it and see what works best
for you
but uh just wanted to show you that
although white will always be able to
attack
if you feel comfortable and you know the
the intricacies of the position you will
be able to defend and
it's gonna be it's gonna be a great
victory for you you know
maybe uh but okay uh just uh what i
wanted to show you after this queen
captures on b2 what happens if white
decides to just
castle and say let's let's brawl it out
but the most important and the most
dangerous line is the next one
and that is knight to d5 white defends
the rook
with the queen but also offers an early
queen trade
and also threatens knight the c7 check
so here what would happen is we have to
capture the queen so here we trade
queens
captures and then white has this fish
and so uh
knight the c7 with check going after the
king
and the in the rook here king to d8 and
now of course you have to recapture the
queen now of course our rook is hanging
so we have to play rook to a7
and now white wins back his pawn with
knight c captures on e6
grabs the pawn and eliminates the knight
here that's now undefended
due to rook to a7 so here we're going to
play d captures an e6 you usually want
to capture towards the center but
this would just uh we would get three
pawn islands in the position and
that's not very good two-point islands
are better than three unless it's uh you
know
working by force you usually don't want
to mess up your pawn structure
so d captures on e6 bishop captures on
v8 rook to a8 and
now you're you have to move the bishop
bishop somewhere let's say bishop to g3
and now you continue development bishop
to b for check
king to f1 there's no no better move and
now
you're gonna go knight to e4 you're
gonna try and eliminate this bishop
because
white's bishop pair it will be very
strong if you don't react very early on
so i suggest doing something like this
and after let's say knight b3 you're
gonna capture on g3h captures and go
king to e7
and again it seems like a very weird
position for black to play because it
seems
like white has some very natural moves
whereas black doesn't but
if you know what you're doing this is
perfectly fine and now i'm going to show
you
how to uh how to set your pieces up
optimally
and for those of you if you're maybe
wondering if how do i
know all this why am i even talking
about such things
uh i've i've done the research i've uh
you know browsed
the database i've seen what what you
know people play at
the top level and what works what
doesn't end i've analyzed everything
with the engine
uh the most important crucial lines i've
left the engine to crunch the numbers at
around the depth 40. so
if you if you usually analyze lines
in a in a depth you know the higher than
depth 40 then
uh again i will say this chances are you
are not
watching my videos but if you're a
casual player at this will be
this will be more than more than
sufficient so
uh all right now let's see let's see
some developing moves rook to b1
uh putting the rook on a nice semi open
b file we're gonna go
rook to b8 uh rook the h4 going after
the bishop here
bishop back to b6 and now let's say
knight d2 going after
our bishop here we're gonna play b5 this
is how we're gonna get all of our pieces
into the game
and now uh like i said uh once black
pushes d5 b5 white has the
a and c pawn that you can use to trade
off
one of your isolated pawns so let's say
c4 now we're going to go bishop to d7
and after let's say c captures on b5 a
captures
you're going to get knight the e4 going
after the bishop
but now bishop bishop to a3 and that's
it
you're gonna you're you're gonna have a
lot of fun playing this you still have
the bishop
pair uh the position is very open and
you know you
you you have to enjoy the advantage of
the bishop pair for example if rook to
b3 you can even play b
b4 go after the rook here just challenge
it and
it's going to be a very pleasant
position let's say 92 you can even play
rook to c8 you don't care about this
pawn because this will be deadly for
white and
white really needs the white really
needs to figure out how he will continue
playing this position
uh because uh although white's white was
a bit more active when we entered the
end game
uh you see that there was actually
nothing to worry about you can
you can you you have time to place your
pieces on optimal squares
and you will be able to play this so now
white is the one that will be struggling
and pretty much in all of the lines not
pretty much in all of the lines that
we've shown uh if you know what you're
doing white will be struggling
and it's just something that that is the
case here
so of course white will find many many
ways to make your life miserable
and uh just knowing this one line will
not be
and not be enough but it does show you
that
you can feel safe in any of the
positions that arise and you will know
that okay
even though this is the position now uh
i can
find something because i know that i am
safe in this position so
you know it will further motivate you to
look for better moves in in your
positions
so just to go over the line one more
time uh we're just gonna show it once
again
and mention something that we've already
mentioned just along the way so d4
knight to f6 and the once black white
goes for bishop to f4
we go c5 that's what we do it because we
set knight f6
c5 queen b6 and a6 uh we don't worry
about d5 we already shown why
why is that so e3 and now queen to b6
and now
once white develops we're gonna play a6
and like i said
this will be our basic setup we're gonna
go knight to f3
white's maybe most serious attempt now
e6
and now after bishop to e2 we're gonna
go uh captures
queen captures and of course queen
captures on v2
so in the main line that we're
discussing we actually captured the b2
pawn
and now like we said white can choose to
play a bit more aggressive
with with castles white can play any
move here now this is not the only move
i can play rook to b one white can play
h for y can play where i can play
whatever white wants to play
uh not right away h4 because the rook is
hanging but uh
uh there are different ways white can
play this but uh
uh i just wanted you to know that there
is nothing to worry about regardless of
what white plays
you just have to know your way around
the position so we will probably see
something like knights here
uh and then we go into the very very
first line so what's
beautiful about the uh all of these
lines that i've shown
is that they are force forcing lines and
uh
the lines that i've shown is where white
makes the absolute best move so white
needs to make
the absolute best moves in all of these
lines uh to always be a little bit worse
if white
doesn't play the best moves white will
always be white will always be worse
so here knight to d5 we're gonna go
captures on d4
knight to c7 check and now everything
like we said we're gonna go here
recapture and then this rook to a7 and
gets the rook out of the way captures on
e6 captures
uh white recaptures the piece and now
like we said this could be
very dangerous but since you know how to
play this bishop to be for check some
rapid development
it's gonna be very fine for you king f1
now knight to e4 we want to eliminate
white's bishop pair that's kind of what
we're going for here
uh and there's no way for white to avoid
this if you try and save the bishop here
there's always f6 g5 so you will win
that pawn
uh that bishop so let's say we said
knights to b3 we're gonna exchange here
white can play any other set of moves
but your your basic
idea of a setup is the same king is
seven you want to get the rook into the
game you don't want to castle or
anything like that because
uh well you've already moved your king
obviously so
rook to b1 like we said rook to b8
you're preparing to push this b
pawn rook to h4 it's not a problem white
has immense activity but
there is nothing white can do to prevent
you from activating your pieces if b5 c4
bishop to d7
and it's just a very enjoyable position
captures captures and
now after going after your bishop
there's this bishop to a3 safe haven
uh that will allow you to go for b4 and
so on like we said
very very tricky line uh so
this is the mo this is a line that will
never happen in your own games unless
like
i don't know i have no idea what what
would have to align for this to happen
in your own games but
just to show you that uh all the
scariest things that can happen
cannot hurt you so like we said rook b3
b4
going after even bishop to h5 could be
very scary at some point
but knight d2 and now let's say rook c8
goes after rook to c1
and the black's position is just better
period
so yeah now we've covered a lot of uh
some very interesting lines but
uh that's what i wanted to create
what i was basically trying to do i was
trying to create something that i can
use myself to
uh play against the london system and
i've tried it out a little bit against
twenty one hundred twenty two hundred
twenty three hundred players and it
it works perfectly white never got uh
uh even even close to a position as good
as the positions i've shown here
but of course when you face stronger
players white will of course be more
resilient find better ideas and so on
and so on
uh but know that your position is solid
and that you know
there's nothing bad that can happen if
you don't mess up
as usual uh so yeah this is the setup
just remember this you have to have this
mental image in your head always
this is it so we're gonna go knight f6
c5 queen b6 a6 and that's it that's our
setup against the london
and we are going to uh
enjoy this uh playing this uh very much
so uh i i don't know i've never
understood uh
what a setup is actually the london
system does the knight have to be on f3
for it to officially be the london
system or is the bishop f4 e3 d4 setup
already the london system so
it's very vague but uh basically this is
an anti-london setup not a
setup against not a setup against the
the london system but basically the
anti-london so i guess it doesn't matter
uh but yeah this is what we'll be
playing and um
yeah let me know how it goes if uh you
will be having any more luck
uh if you're if you enjoy extremely
sharp
positions uh and you know a lot of
sacrifices everything like
i do uh you might not find this opening
idea that interesting but if you don't
mind just trading off
you know pieces queens and going for
straight out into an end game
with the black pieces with white having
nothing then this is this is definitely
something for you
so that's the opening hope you guys
enjoyed it let me know let me know how
it goes
uh always remember this setup it's not
not very difficult to remember so you
know
let me know how it goes and will you uh
be having more or
less fun playing against the london
after you've seen this video
so maybe just go through the lines a few
times because there's like
five of them to remember and you don't
have to remember
all you know the big sausages of lines
but you know maybe just uh
uh the ideas ended a few moves behind
them and then you will
probably you know face some other moves
but then you will have to prepare for
those moves as well this is just a
foundation to build upon but yeah okay
enough said uh thank you
thank you all for watching uh i would
like to thank edward snellgrove
derek king david kimura uh benjamin
rosen and maximilian maher for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the of the
tata steel chess tournament checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and uh whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day
and destroy that london system once and
for all